it's difficult to
to say that i was a slave
that sounds terrible to feels terrible
dan was threatened beaten and forced to
sell drugs for a man who turned him into
a modern day slave
the ordeal only ended when dan got
arrested and police figured out what had
been going on
in this interview filmed by the
salvation army he describes the abuse
meted out by the man who had initially
befriended him it was the threats of
violence towards my loved ones that
really
was the hardest
when someone tells you that they're
going to beat your mother up that is
no man no woman ever wants to hear her
he just made me feel terrified
shocking as it is dan's case is all too
common a tale
2
62 survivors of modern slavery in
england and wales were referred to the
salvation army for help from july 2020
to june 2021
470 had been forced to commit crimes
such as growing or dealing drugs begging
and shoplifting that's up 62 percent
as a result of the pandemic we have seen
quite a significant increase in the
number of individuals being referred
into the national referral mechanism
which can be seen through either manners
of county lines forcing at people or
coocooing apartments in order to
continue with cannabis growth
john renouff is one of hundreds of
salvation army volunteers who pick up
victims of modern slavery and drive them
to a safe house where they can get the
help they need
there are no stereotypes that you can't
say it's limited to one particular
nationality or one particular age group
we've moved people
of wide age ranges from 18 through to
their early 70s
i think the number of nationalities that
have been helped is i think 70 or 80.
the economic and mental health impact of
the pandemic may have made more people
vulnerable to the kind of exploitation
dan suffered
as circumstances change criminals adapt
their methods to keep making money no
matter how much misery they cause
ender brady sky news